we debated what we should announce today
should we announce four and five we've
planned them out we've got five years
down the road and I was like I think you
got 11 projects in two years is plenty
having not mentioned anything four to
two or three years how's it going
everybody it's Warren and welcome back
to the channel as if the Marvel
Cinematic Universe wasn't already
exciting enough with the beginning of
phase four right around the corner with
Black Widow only a few months away we
have actually gotten a lot of phase 5
news and as you just saw Kevin Feige say
in an interview with MTV News phase 5 is
done the lineup is complete Marvel has a
five-year plan so they have the next
five years of the MCO completely planned
out in fact we have the release dates
for every film that Marvel is going to
release between now and 2020 3 and as it
turns out it looks like we seem to know
every single movie that they're going to
be releasing as well in phase 5 there
have been a lot of confirmations
recently about movies coming out in
phase 5 and Kevin Feige the president of
Marvel Studios himself has even
confirmed some movies that we can expect
so I'm gonna talk about these leaks I'm
going to talk about every single movie
that we can expect to see in phase 5
what the phase 5 slate is most likely
going to look like and every single
thing that we know about all of the
movies if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU I'm also
given away in Xbox one or ps4 and all
you have to do is be subscribed with
notifications turned on leave a like on
the video and drop a comment below I
pick in a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers so Marvel has
recently revealed all of their phase 5
release dates from 2022 through 2023 and
so far only one of the slots has been
revealed and confirmed and that is blacc
panther2 in May of 2022 now this is
going to be the second movie released of
phase 5 they also have a slot reserved
for February of 2022 which will be the
first slide the entire slate goes as
followed February 2022 May 2000 2000
2000 22 and October 2022 we then move on
to the next year and we have February
2023 made 2023 and November 2023 these
are all of the release dates that Marvel
currently
has set for phase five that's four
movies a year more than they usually do
but that makes perfect sense because
Marvel now has a lot more new characters
to work with including the x-men the
Fantastic Four and of course Deadpool
but now what are these movies well if we
look at everything that Kevin Feige has
said about phase 5 and look at the
movies that he has already confirmed to
be in development we pretty much know
what the slate is going to be after San
Diego comic-con in 2019 Kevin Feige
revealed that he decided last minute to
not talk about phase 5 and stick to
phase 4 however that did not stop him
from talking about a few movies before
Marvel's panel at San Diego comic-con
wrapped up Kevin Feige took the time to
announce blade and bring Maher Sheila
Ali on stage and although they don't
have a set release date yet they did
take the time to announce it at San
Diego Comicon bring Maher Sheila Ali in
and show the blade logo and since
they've cast their main character and
have a logo made for the movie already
things are well underway and it's very
unlikely that they would announce this
if blade wasn't coming pretty soon in
phase 5 so both of those phase 5 movies
were revealed but then Kevin Feige
mentioned some other movies before he
got off the stage
[Applause]
inconvenient we didn't mention the fact
that Gardens galaxy 3 is coming time to
talk about Captain Marvel - I didn't
even have time to talk about the
Fantastic Four
[Applause]
there's no time left to talk about a
mutant
[Applause]
so Kevin Feige name drops black panther
to captain marvel to guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 and then the x-men and the
Fantastic Four now it seems very
unlikely that Kevin Feige would mention
these names unless they were coming
relatively soon
why tease us if the film's are going to
be developed for a while and of course
this was confirmed at Disney's d23 event
where Kevin Feige announced Black
Panther 2 and it's official release date
of May of 2022 and of course as we know
from its release date it is going to be
in phase 5 and then just yesterday we
got confirmation for Captain Marvel -
there hasn't really been any word about
Captain Marvel - for a very long time
despite Kevin Feige officially
announcing it at San Diego Comicon but
yesterday The Hollywood Reporter
announced that Captain Marvel 2 now has
a writer
Megan MacDonald and Megan is also a
writer on the Wanda vision series but
they also revealed that Captain Marvel 2
is I in a 2022 release date that would
put it in phase 5 which of course makes
perfect sense because Kevin Feige
announced it at San Diego Comicon now so
far it's been reported by a few people
including Daniel RPK that were most
likely going to be getting the Secret
Invasion storyline for Captain Marvel 2
originally in the comics this involves
the Skrull shape-shifting into Avengers
which obviously causes a big problem
however in the MCU and Captain Marvel
the scroll are actually revealed to be
good so if they do go the secret
invasion story route it's most likely
going to be the Kree who are invading
the earth or some scroll who have
actually gone bad and then of course
Kevin Feige dropped guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 there's been a lot of drama
in regards to guardians 3 there was the
firing of James Gunn which was a really
scary time because he was also the
writer of the film
fortunately Marvel and Disney took him
back however it came at a slight cost
mostly to us fans when James Gunn was
fired he took a job with DC directing
the Suicide Squad and it's already been
confirmed that he can't work on
guardians of the galaxy 3 until he's
done with the Suicide Squad in August of
2021 fortunately for us that is plenty
of time for guardians of the galaxy 3 to
be complete and interphase 5 especially
when you consider the fact that James
Gunn has already confirmed that he has
written the script but still most likely
due for
the 2023 spots so these few movies that
Kevin Feige made sure to mention at the
end of San Diego comic-con have already
been confirmed for phase five but he
also mentioned the Fantastic Four and
the x-men and since the other movies
that he mentioned with them have been
confirmed for Phase five it's most
likely that these are going to be in
phase five as well in fact we've already
gotten some reports from some insiders
in the Marvel community that the
Fantastic Four could be in 2022 and that
report came from MCU cosmic and the
geeks worldwide Kevin Feige has actually
hinted that the Fantastic Four would
most likely come before the x-men and
that makes sense because the Fantastic
Four are just four individuals the x-men
have so many different characters to
choose from it's going to be a lot
harder to introduce them than it is to
introduce the Fantastic Four first
however Kevin Feige has confirmed that
Marvel Studios has been thinking about
what to do with these characters for
years now even before the deal with Fox
was complete but of course the deal has
been complete for some time now in Kevin
Feige and Marvel Studios has well over
four years to consider what they're
going to do with the Fantastic Four and
the x-men and recently Kevin Feige
actually revealed a deleted post-credit
scene from Iron Man at one that revealed
the x-men in the post credit scene Nick
Fury says assorted mutants mutants
weren't enough I have to deal with a
spoiled brat who doesn't play well with
others and wants to keep all his toys to
himself
Nick Fury director of shield now of
course at the time they couldn't
actually use that because they didn't
have the rights to use the x-men in the
MCU however this does go to show that
Marvel Studios has been planning on the
x-men being a part of the MCU for a very
long time over eleven years and as far
as the x-men are concerned we've gotten
a report from Mikey Sutton another
insider that say some of the x-men could
make an appearance and phase four this
was further backed up by the fact that
Patrick Stewart who plays Professor
Xavier in the Fox Universe recently
revealed that he met with Kevin Feige
himself to talk about Professor X in the
MCU now despite the fact that it's
simply
incredible that Marvel Studios would
even consider bringing back Patrick
Stewart's Professor Xavier in the MCU
what this does tell us is that the x-men
are well on their way in fact there's
been a report from the Twitter account
smart Tom that what they wanted
Professor Xavier for it was a cameo and
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness so if this is true and Marvel is
planning on introducing the x-men in
some shape or form in phase four they
can definitely do it in phase five and
then we have Ant Man 3 this was recently
confirmed by Michael Douglas who of
course plays Hank Pym and Michael
Douglas has recently confirmed that
ant-man is going to start production in
January of 2021 which of course gives us
plenty of time for a phase 5 release
date in 2022 or 2023 so that's 7 of the
8 movie slots that are for phase 5 and
all of those movies are pretty much
confirmed so that leaves us with one
movie left and it could be one of three
different movies and I'm going to start
off with Deadpool 3 Deadpool 3 has
already been confirmed to be in the
works and Marvel Studios by Ryan
Reynolds himself and not to mention that
prior to this Ryan Reynolds teased
Deadpool 3 for phase 5 he posted on
Instagram about Deadpool with the
caption investigation heading into year
5 or as I call it phase 5
so if Deadpool 3 is already in
development then it's definitely going
to be in phase 5 unless Marvel Studios
decides to not include it in the main
Marvel Cinematic Universe there is a
possibility that Marvel Studios will
allow Deadpool to remain rated R but the
consequence may be not to be included in
the timeline Deadpool will exist in the
MCU and the events that take place in
the MCU will affect what happens in the
movie however may not affect the MCU and
the movies that exist within if Marvel
goes this route then Deadpool 3 won't
technically be included in phase 5
however as it seems right now Deadpool 3
will most likely be in phase 5 but in
case he's not there are other options
and one of those options are the Thunder
bolts a few days ago Daniel RPK reported
that the Falcon and the Winter Soldier
series is going to set up the thunder
bullets and the MCU it's possible that
during the Falcon and the Winter Soldier
series and through other shows and
movies in phase four the Thunderbolts
will be introduced and then they will
eventually get their own film and this
is likely if Marvel Studios doesn't want
to introduce another New Avengers group
for some time
however if Marvel does want to introduce
the New Avengers and Deadpool three
isn't going to technically be a part of
phase five that's the movie that it's
going to be Kevin Feige has confirmed
that he does already know who the new
Avengers team is going to be and that it
is going to be very different could the
next Avengers we see be Young Avengers
have you guys thought about like you
know what the next of interesting looks
like yes and it will be it will be a
very different team than we've seen
before that's what endgame was all about
yeah it would be a very different
incarnation of the team with some people
you've already met and some people you
haven't met so either Deadpool 3 the
Thunderbolts or the New Avengers team is
going to be that final slot in the phase
5 lineup based off of everything that we
know all of the confirmations and what
Kevin Feige said at San Diego comic-con
this is most likely the entire phase 5
lineup now another thing to mention is
that Marvel has confirmed three Disney
plus TV shows miss Marvel Moon night and
she Hulk but these are actually rumored
to be a part of phase four they just
haven't been announced yet there's
always a chance that these could be in
phase five and which of course this
lineup will be rearranged by three
movies but unless that happens this is
pretty much the lineup based off of
everything we know so what do you think
about this would you be excited to with
these movies in phase five let me know
what you like and let me know what you
would change let me know down below also
don't forget to give the video a like
and subscribe when notifications turned
on so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU giveaway
details are below and don't forget to
follow me on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof